learning from interventions and i have
three wonderful speakers this morning
actually two of them my colleagues from
berkeley one from stem for very local
session and all the speakers will be in
person
and
the first speaker is
from
my department very glad to have fun here
he's speaking on estimating every
treatment effect in randomized
experiments missing covariates so just
like yesterday
you can ask clarification questions and
we have a panel later
so here you go
okay thank you bing for the kind
introduction
this is the first talk for today i will
talk about something very classic and
simple
obviously not a two days for the
audience uh as the title suggests i will
talk about coverage adjustment in
randomized trial but with missing
coverage this is a journal to work with
auntie john my collaborator from a
national university of finger singapore
we know randomized experiments are good
standard for unbiased estimation of
treatment effects because if you run a
randomized trial you can simply
take difference in means of the treated
and control group that's an unbiased
estimator if you like list the squares
you can just run a very simple list
experience of what outcome y and the
binary treatment indicator the
coefficient of the difference in means
and it's unbiased has a lot of
properties
there is a also a large literature on
covariate adjustment to further improve
efficiency for example fischer suggested
the textbook recommendation
ancova or linear regression of y on
treatment plus covariance
and later wickstoning from berkeley
statistics
proposes slight modification linear
regression with covariate treatment
interaction and he show
his estimators generally better than
fischers and coba asymptotically there
are some conditions but
if you find that assymtopia a lens
estimator is slightly better
and he also show we can simply report
the robust standard error the ico
huberwise robust standard error from
these squares it's a convenient
approximation to the true standard
neighbor so here why say unbiasedness or
standard error or approximation to the
true standard error
uh our theoretical framework is design
based meaning
we don't assume anything about
the potential outcomes that are all
fixed we don't assume anything about
covariance are all fixed the only random
component
is the treatment indicator z because
where the
the experimenters control the randomness
of the
it's a random permutation
of ones and zeros and
the the the list of squares estimators
are unbiased for the true parameter term
the target is the average
treatment effect average over individual
effect this is a fixed parameter and
there's no modeling assumption so even
even though the formulation
uses these two squares we don't assume
those models are correct so it's a very
classical way of viewing randomized
experiment
and we spent
they will use like 30 pages of proofs in
the papers to show oh those estimates
are nice trying to convince people to to
use those estimators but it's actually
difficult to convince people sometimes
because
the theory says you have efficiency game
but in practice
people may not want to use it or
sometimes misuse it there is a
a reason there are many reasons but
there is a reason like one of my friend
told me oh you told us running
co-various adjustments but when i look
at my data set there are so many missing
values and covariance i don't know how
to how to do it then they just say okay
forget about it just go back to
different things there are some
practical issues
practitioners may not want to
follow our theoretical suggestions so i
will talk about this
practical complication there's some
missingness in covariates
so first is amazing as in cover is a
real problem i i found a a
study from economics do follow at all
they ran
a field experiment in western kenya
trying to estimate the effect of a free
delivery of fertilizer on fertilizer use
about 200
units received treatment and more than
600 units receive control
in total they have 27 calories and you
can imagine
those important ones education
uh previous fertilizer use gender income
and so on
and seven covariates have missing values
and approximately 20 percent of the
units have some missingness okay it's
hard to have complete observation
and this is the missingness pattern in
the original data set so for those seven
covaries uh here one means missing zero
means observed so there are several
patterns quite complicated pattern some
patterns have have large sample size
some patterns have actually smaller
samples and so it's very
this is a real problem in real betas the
missingness pattern
really like this okay
so the default analysis the default
analysis is okay forget about business
just plugging the data set into
r or stata
with missing covaries the default choice
is dropping all the units
with any messiness incorporates this is
called the complete case analysis in the
literature okay
if we don't do covariate adjustment long
regression of y and z
this regression uses all the units if we
run regression of y and z with x either
additive or with interaction
automatically the software packages will
drop illness with any measurements okay
drop 20
in the do-flow example
so the question
is is covariate adjustment based on
complete case analysis already better as
a simple difference it means like the
answer is no i will talk about it but
this is the default
uh method
so the question for today is how do we
deal with missing x in randomized
experiment there are many many methods
there's a book by lisa and rubin
reviewing all the possible methods like
modeling x imputing x
even multiple mutations and offensive
messages there are many measures but the
goal for today is not to
compete
in complexity with those methods just
the opposite we want to adjust for x but
do not want to use complicated measure
i want to recommend easier to implement
measures like it's it's better still to
use these squares but
using it in a
particular way and want to deliver
strong guarantees uh
then naive methods without modeling
assumptions okay
this is our goal but
let me tell you the answer
because it's possible i will be running
out of time so just the take away
messages
the final recommendation is very simple
as i promised so we don't want to
propose complicated messages
we call it is a mission is indicator
method
first we impute
all the missing covalent values by zero
okay just zero
then
we have a covariate matrix and at the
same time we augment that matrix
by missing this indicator matrix so you
have you have any x value associated
with the indicator whether it's missing
or not so you augment your covariate
matrix
then you treat this imputed covariate
and the augmented part means in a single
indicator part together
as the coverage and then move on to
rather standard analysis okay that's our
recommendation and you can also report
like who provides robust standard error
but the talk is to
we'll try to convince you okay why this
message simple measure is recommended
it's not it's not the best measure we
can imagine uh
and i will i will tell you what other
properties
is this simple measure that has okay
it's a non-statistician can you just
tell us what this means so this means
you're sort of
introducing an extra dimension which is
you're missing this indicator and
including that as one of the covariates
yes yeah that's right
squares yeah yeah
exactly and the methods from i'm sorry
well maybe
there's a brief
not again not being a statistician
what's the imputation method
oh just
whenever you have a missing value just
say that's zero
yeah that part i followed
but but that part i followed but then
you say use the augmented covariates in
fischer or lit
oh there is means the original x always
zero for the messiness and the missing
indicator part so we augmented the
original x with the missingness
indicator so this is this together yes
you're not trying to actually impute
what the val what the missing value was
in any substantive way it's just zero
yeah
[Music]
if if we have a covalent vector x i you
have the another vector we call it mi
later the same dimension as x i if if
the this item is observed is
zero otherwise this one so it's
corresponding to x same dimension yeah
okay yeah this is the most important
part hope it's clear that i can talk
about
series hi um so it's the high level idea
roughly
roughly the fact that um you the
algorithm will use the indicator
variables to see whether you make use of
that
dimension if it is missing then
for that unit you will just ignore that
dimension roughly speaking uh so so
oh i will explain the theory later yeah
yeah
there are some reasons why we want to
have this indicator thank you yeah i
will explain it later
now i just want to state the method
okay okay
okay
so so far i haven't i haven't introduced
the formal notation so now it's for
notation
start from the simple but we believe
it's reasonable scenario we let mi be
the missingness indicator vector
corresponding to x i you have x i the
same dimension mi the missing is
indicated and we assume m i y equals m
as 0. so this is the notation the
potential outcome notation saying
the potential outcome notation is
redundant for m this means the treatment
does not affect the business
indicator so this is reasonable in
randomized trial if you collect data
before the experiment because covariates
are
what's happened before the experiment so
it's reasonable in in those cases but it
can be violated sometimes
people collect covaries after the
experiment so we don't really know
whether the mission is depends on
treatment or not but in a lot of
randomized trials this is uh true
by the design because by definition
uh
m happens before the treatment okay
under this assumption if effectively m
is a covariate okay coverage means not
something not affected by the treatment
if we realize x is a covariate a lot of
discussion follows quite naturally later
okay
this seems strong but it's actually
quite weak for example m can be related
to x
can be
related to y one potential outcome y one
y zero in arbitrary waves so this part
is totally
uh arbitrary and so using the standard
terminology will allow for missing not
any random
missing nether and random meaning
missingness can depend on
something unknown
depending on
missing values themselves of x and the
missing potential becomes okay so this
is the assumption
we impose for the for the most part
yeah so so your assumption about mu i y
equal to my i2 and then the false one
do they have to work together or they
can be independently checked
which one the first one depending on the
potential outcomes yeah arbitrary way
yeah if i then but you have to impose
they are the same yeah so so if they're
the same so we just call this mr okay so
beyond this assumption other parts are
arbitrary
yeah
well basically we say m is like a
coherent
it's
similar to x
oh it's it's the
existing potential sorry
yeah yeah
let me review the the methods
first one is a complete case analysis i
reviewed before it's a default one if
you run these squares with standard
statistical software packages
it's obvious this method will lose
efficiency if many units miss at least
some coverage value but more importantly
it's problematic because complete cases
may not represent
all units
so it's not only efficiency but also
bias
okay this is a good reason for some
practitioners to avoid the covariate
adjustment because they don't want to
face this complexity and say okay let's
go back to use different means
networks
okay so it's widely used but we
discovered using it
the second method you got is called
complete covariate analysis so if i
think
if any covariates
have only missingness just drop down the
column so complete case is dropping rows
complete covariation answer is the
dropping columns if this column of x
has a missingness just drop it so we
only keep this complete
okay
at least this method we don't drop units
those units are still representative of
the original
trial
and this simple
both syrian practice is simple and
if there are some completely observed
covariates we still have efficiency
again so we use this as a benchmark in
our discussion if whatever proposed
cannot beat this method as a ban method
okay because this method is simple and
have some efficiency again at least it's
not ideal
but it's not banned
okay if all of your co-values have some
missingness value then we drop all co
varies and go back to
our adjusted estimator okay but
it can be inferior in efficiency if most
covariates have business
okay so there's a second method
the third one is also standard because
single imputation we just impute
impute the missing value of the gs
covalent by cg by a constant cg in
theory cj can even be data dependent for
example imputed by the the mean of the
observed covariance of this column
that's also widely used either including
by zero observed means
and we can just view
the imputed covariates as the pseudo
covariance and move on to to apply
coverage adjustment let's understand the
methods so this might be
have been used
a lot in practice okay people just okay
do some imputation
and the theory depends on those cgs
but
we can't even
optimize over those cgs so you can
imagine have
the
freedom to choose p p parameters cg here
and we do not discuss complex
computation schemes here because
generally sub-optimal
imputation sub-optimal
and in the literature some some someone
proposed multiple imputation
it seems overkill in our case because we
have a better and simpler method than
multiple imputation
okay
but at least
the single imputation measures don't
drop any covariates okay so you use as
much information as possible
are do you also compare your method uh
in the future slides with a method where
you actually have an oracle observation
for every culinary observed and then
compare the efficiencies
oh actually don't compare it yeah but
it's a good question yeah if we have the
oracle yeah
yeah so if you want to answer questions
yeah
yeah so the question was whether if
there is any point like comparing to the
oracle
oracle method where essentially you your
god and you actually observe all the
covariates and compare that to yeah yeah
yeah yeah we don't compare that yeah
yeah
but it's a good theoretical question
here we just say okay what if we don't
observe or x what can we do yeah uh a
clarification on the previous slide you
talked about imputation uh does this
also include amputation with like
contextual imputation where you train
regressors or classifiers based on the
other variables and include different
different values for every sample yeah
that's another standard method of
imputation but here we we skip it
because
because we have a better message later
yeah
yeah like input complex imputation is
dominated by something else
yeah
the fourth message the recommended one
the missingness indicator message so we
impute
missing covariance or by zero now we go
x i input viewing example as well as mi
together as pseudo covariates so we we
move on using
x impute and mi together in covalent
adjustment and the report is a standard
robust standard error so here you might
be surprised why i just
boldly recommend
using zero what if the covariate has a
value from 100 to 1000 imputed by zero
seems like a strange idea
but it's not restrictive as long as we
include missions indicator m i we can
show
the estimate is invariant
to the imputed value cg so no matter
what value cg you use as long as you
include mi
the coefficient of mi will will absorb
the value of the input imputation so
using 0 is not restricted so both point
estimate and standard error are
invariant to the choice of cg as long as
you include mi
this is true not only for these squares
actually if you use other measures it's
still true just because of
parametrization
yeah
that's why it's easy to remember that's
zero okay
and another reason for us to recommend
this is to compare with single
imputation of course
you can just twist like how to optimize
over cg but
we don't want to give too much research
degrees of freedom to researchers
because they can search over different
cgs and report whatever in favor was
their study they said publish the
results okay so
so just want to get rid of that
arbitrators okay as long as you include
mri
in variance oh
okay
and that's another another reason why we
recommend this method
okay the mim business indicator method
uses all covariance and all units always
improves the efficiency over
our digested complete covalent and
single imputation there's no dependence
on the imputed value because of the
algebraic property are very easy to
implement by these two squares there's
no need to model missing data mechanism
and co-varies and it works even if the
missing data mechanism depends on the
mixing covers themselves
and even
works even if the outcome model is wrong
okay so that's our recommendation
but this message is not new at all like
we didn't even just mention this very
old method but not very popular in the
literature it was like first reference i
i found this
psychology
it was used a lot in observational
studies which is a little ironic
because we can show
in observational studies message does
not work
but it's widely used the there not
otherwise they used in randomized trial
and we show in randomized trial it works
because here we have randomization
randomization justifies
this method okay without randomization
this can be a banned measure there were
several papers
here
both simulation and series showing does
not work
and we provide a design based theory
like without modeling assumptions
showing this is a good idea and it is in
in randomized trials
okay usually will we go to statistics
papers we have to propose something new
if we say oh this is this is not new at
all
statisticians will be disappointed
so so we have to propose some something
slightly new we don't recommend this but
we just say theoretically
theoretically this is for siri
theoretically you can further improve it
okay if you have that type of data okay
so we call it the mission is pattern
method it's it's also a very simple
method so business pattern means
combination of all the business
indicators many ways a combination if
you have two missing covariance there
are four possible
patterns like both observed one observed
other way and both missing so
and you can imagine
this can be general
uh missing this pattern method is also
intuitive one sentence is just use
whatever covariance we have
don't do any imputation just imagination
don't do fancy measures if you only have
a subset of of the coverage use them
okay so this is our proposal we first
stratify units based on the business
patterns
okay first do the stratification second
within each business pattern all the
units have the same set of covariance
general regression
using those covaries for those units
and across missions pattern take away
the average
okay
this is also not new if you if you go
deep to the literature
sometimes appear in the appendix okay
well nothing is using in randomized
trial so
in the case with two two covariance like
there are four patterns for the first
pattern you have both just from
regression with both x
in in the second and third you have only
one covariate just strong regression
with that one covariate in the last path
you don't have any covaries just on
different settings
and obtain the coefficients integrated
average okay so nothing fancy actually
and in some sense it's
it's intuitive right what what else can
we do we don't have
those missing x like you imputed values
are fixed values like how can we gain
anything from those fake values right so
here just use whatever you have
okay somewhat we believe is
this method is transparent without uh
imputation just use all available
coverage information for all your nets
but it's much more demanding sample size
you have to
really have that regime all missing this
pattern have enough data points for you
to run that regression like if you
recall the two flow example some
miscellaneous patterns only have one
unit
some have have two now you cannot really
run this regression so you have to do
something like
more fancy like clap some some business
patterns so uh but but if you are in a
nice regime with enough data points
for
all business patterns we recommend this
one but in reality it's hard to have
this nice regime okay so in theory it's
better
in practice you have to be careful
so what are the properties of this
business pattern method
now there are different ways to view it
one way to do it is
the post-stratified estimator view you
just
view the business pattern as a discrete
covariate
you you stratify online discrete
covalent within each strata you can do
whatever you can do which is coverage
adjustment and this is we call it the
conditional view you're conditioning on
the business pattern
and and
there was a paper by uh look gas and
being on post stratification so in some
sense we just follow that idea but apply
stratification on end
okay
the second way
because in the paper you want to compare
different methods most measures we
discussed were following a so-called
unconditional where we don't
conditioning on the missingness pattern
so we can show algebraically this
measure that effectively uses
the imputed x
missing indicators and their higher all
their interactions is a regression
okay if i if i say it in this way you
might say oh this is a crazy message why
do we think all the higher order
interactions matter for the outcome but
again it's theoretical interest if you
have enough data points you can do this
very greedy
adjustment including all higher order
interactions
and this is
a way to to write the estimator like in
terms of these squares
and if you write in this way the theory
follows immediately oh well it works i
could help provide standard error also
works and so on and also the efficiency
follows because you use so many uh
covariance in the regression in theory
the more covariance you use the more
efficiency gain you have so in theory
this is better
let me summarize
complete case analysis is not
recommended because it's biased in
general complete covariate analysis it's
okay it's the benchmark measures
uh single imputation is also okay but
there are some problems like not
invariant to imputed values not fully
efficient
the missingness indicator method is
close to single imputation
but it has other
nice properties like in variance to the
imputation and slightly more efficient
than imputation and the missing
expansion method
requires large sample size for all the
business patterns so in series better
but you have to be careful whether you
are in the assignment required by this
message
okay so another summary just make this a
claim more precise the efficiency again
comparison were based on
uh uh linux estimator not based on
fishers uh
ancova because uh david friedman the
paper is saying the encore estimator can
be a bad estimator there's no
efficiency guarantee in theory so if we
apply link's estimator indeed there is a
efficiency ordering business pattern the
best business indicator
in the middle that is recommended and
dominant domain many other methods okay
it's intuitive because the more
comparisons we have the more efficiency
we have okay
have only one minute so one slide
so let's do some comparison so missiles
pattern measure that uses imputed x
those missions indicators and all their
interactions
missing this indicator uses
their main terms actually there's no
higher order interaction so you can
imagine there are many choices in the
middle like
maybe you only believe first order and
second or the interaction not not the gs
order interaction that's too much
and other measures
going down other methods can use the
imputed covaries and
not necessarily all the indicators
because if you look at the data
sometimes
the missingness indicators are highly
correlated if x1 is missing maybe x2 is
missing with very high probability these
two columns are
highly related if you use all the
missingness indicator it can be
problematic
so in general you can also
regress a little bit saying don't use
all the indicators but use a function of
those indicators if you are in the
regime those columns of aims are highly
correlated
so in the in also in psychology actually
in the factor analysis literature
someone proposed
using a special function just count how
many missing items you have
for each unit so it's not only indicated
by the counting counting the missing
items like as a reduction
of the indicator but here you can think
about the general general function
and
from the adjusted estimator to the fully
adjusted the business pattern method
there are so many
model choices there's a range of
choice like in this talk we didn't talk
about
uh
data dependent choice of the model we
just say okay if you choose this model
there are some trade-offs but in in
general you can think about
uh data dependent like model selection
and so on the for example the lasso
other versions yeah
how would these compare with matrix
completion
i don't know i don't know
yeah yeah that's a maybe another way to
improve
you can do that
just a
quick clarification here so when you say
that
that mp uses their full interactions
it's the interactions among the
missingness indicators you don't also
interact that with uh also with x but if
you're imputing zero as the
um
as that missing value aren't those going
to be
like aren't all those interactions doing
numerically zero as well
yes that's
up to you narrative oh i see i see yeah
i see so if you guys are including
arabic you should just drop that column
that's a good point
some technical issues
yeah thank you
well i think we should send the
questions to our schedules
okay
[Applause]